nous nous excusons tellement pour nous-mêmes nous nous
excusons pour l'espace que nous prenons
ou dans le monde nous nous excusons pour nos
expériences et nos opinions et ce que
j'aime chez Colette, c'est qu'elle ne l'a pas fait
et j'ai trouvé cette
[musique] incroyablement inspirante
qu'elle a explorée  son identité et elle a
exploré sa sexualité sans honte et
je pense encore aujourd'hui que c'est
quelque chose que nous ne faisons pas nous ne
nous explorons pas nous-mêmes ou notre sexualité
sans honte je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
honte autour de tout ça
[Musique]
je pense  vous avez besoin de voir des femmes comme ça
qui l'ont fait qui
ont été là et ont en quelque sorte combattu leur
combat pour que vous sachiez que vous pouvez
combattre le vôtre quand j'avais environ 14 ans je
cherchais vraiment quelqu'un comme ça
à regarder je pense  c'est une femme vraiment cool
et je pense encore une fois au fait
qu'elle a juste trouvé un monde dans lequel les
règles n'avaient pas de sens pour elle et
les limites n'avaient pas de sens pour
elle, alors elle l'a juste déchiré, je
veux toujours  aspirer à voir  des choses que je ne
pense pas justes ou que je ne pense pas
bien et comme les déchirer et en quelque sorte
essayer de les écrire le monde change
tu sais il y a dix ans je ferais des
interviews tu ne pourrais pas mentionner le féminisme
tu pourrais  ne mentionnez pas le fait que les femmes
n'étaient pas égales vous ne pouviez rien mentionner à
propos de tout cela est-ce que ça
va changer du jour au lendemain et tout
ira bien non bien sûr ce n'est pas
ça va prendre des gens d'une jeune
génération pour  continuer ce combat et
ne pas accepter l'inégalité il faudra que
chaque adolescente y aille
je veux ma part de ce gâteau je veux que ma
voix soit entendue je veux avoir un salaire égal je
veux avoir un droit sur mon propre corps
tu sais que ça va prendre  qui se battent
cette prochaine génération pour faire cela dire continuer